التاريخ مهم، التاريخ مهم،
والتاريخ الأسود مهم، انظر، لا أستطيع أن
أختار فقط أن نتعلم ما نريد أن نعرفه،
نحن نتعلم ما يجب أن نعرفه، علينا أن
نتعلم كل شيء، الجيد والسيئ،
الحقيقة
ومن نحن كأمة، هذه هي
الأمم العظيمة  افعل هذا ما
تفعله الأمم العظيمة ونحن أمة عظيمة
ولكن وبالمناسبة تعلم أنني لست أنا،
قد أكون فتى أبيض ولكني لست غبيًا، أعرف
أين تكمن القوة، أعرف أين
تعتقد أنني  أنا
أمزح
في أمريكا الكراهية لن تسود الكراهية لن
تسود الصمت هو
حجم التواطؤ ولن نبقى صامتين الإنكار
أسوأ
وغير مقبول نرى حيوية
الثقافة السوداء والتاريخ يثري
الحياة الأمريكية كلها كل الأمريكيين
تاريخ الحياة الذي لا يمكن دفنه لأنه
يعيش في روح هذه الأمة، إنه
هويتنا، علينا فقط أن نتذكر [
تصفيق]
عليك فقط أن تتذكر من نحن،
نحن الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية، لا
يوجد شيء يفوق قدرتنا
لا شيء لا شيء لا شيء